man muss ja irgendwie im gespräch
bleiben aber ein einfacher arbeitsbesuch
hätte wirklich gereicht dass erdogan
heute abend im schloss bellevue diniert
während wir hier senden ist für mich
eine moralische bankrotterklärung
wirklich es gibt übrigens noch
restkarten für die veranstaltung ja
einige dabei hat der steinmeier extra
whatsapp gruppe eingerichtet mit ja
mittel großem erfolg die gruppe heißt
lecker essen mit ergo angela hat als
erster ab gesagt sorry freitagabend habe
ich zum war christian lindner schreibt
ich es nicht mit despoten macht gerade
intervall fasten robert habeck neder
läuft soko leipzig volker kauder
schreibt ich hab grad echt andere
probleme und selbst mehr so mögen sie
recht gern gekommen hat aber einen
fototermin mit kim jong un
man muss
das war ja gestern mit war gestern die
meldung eine deutschland hat der türkei
die em 2024 weggeschnappt riesen jubel
gestern auch bei den kollegen verstehe
ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht doch im
prinzip egal wo wir verlieren oder naja
com
dafür bringt kann mich um wie gesagt wie
gesagt dialog ist wichtig auch mit der
türkei aber warum so viel tamtam für
erdogan warum wir schalten mal leicht
zum staatsbankett im schloss bellevue zu
albrecht humboldt der zwar nicht rein
darf aber vor der tür wartet und sich
wie ich sehe erschrecken schick gemacht
hat ja entschuldigung ich habe mich halt
so zurecht gemacht wie man sich zurecht
macht wenn der wichtigste türke der welt
in da house ist es ist das
gesellschaftliche event wirklich alles
was in berlin rang und namen hat ist
heute abend nicht gekommen
herzlich willkommen zu
und schauen sie
wirklich jetzt man kann doch mal eine
pause machen mit journalisten im knast
und dem ganzen deprimierenden scheiß
einmal einen schönen abend haben wo ein
ort der erde wagen schafft die
demokratie ab aber wie er sich auf dem
roten teppich bewegt ist der hammer hier
bilder von eben der sultan trägt ein
extrem körperbetonten anzug von guido
maria kretschmer die first lady einen
friesennerz von katie wunderbar
und da kommt der erste gang oder der
nächste gang ist lammschulter das passt
ja super weil das motto des abends ist
lapp drüber das motto des abends lautet
wohl eher wie kriegen wir den saal
volles wollte noch keiner hin
das stimmt doch gar nicht viele
prominente sind daher zb der der der
allerdings und und jan ullrich der ist
extra der extra aus mallorca darüber
gerade aber ein bisschen sensibel war
tatsächlich der sitzplan für das bankett
hier sitzen die erdogan und die
steinmeiers am nebentisch cem özdemir
umringt von erdogans leibwächtern dann
sind zugegebenermaßen ein paar tische
leer geblieben und hier hier in der ecke
am katzentisch sitzt jan böhmermann
ja
der der herren immer man will um 12 wohl
noch ein gedicht vorlesen keine ahnung
ich glaube das wird ein ganz
unterhaltsamer abend und gleich werden
in saal hier
diese konfetti kanonen gezündet randvoll
mit geschredderten türkischen geld
scheiben 3 milliarden liter das sind
umgerechnet vier euro sind
die after show party fängt an
ich gucke rat mal wer da auf legt sie
sich heuer
[Musik]
[Applaus]
keine politik über die schlimme bilder
[Musik]